I suffer from short-term memory loss
yeah that's exactly what you say okay
okay we'll pretend to be the other kids
now uh-huh
hi Dori oh hi there you want to play
hide-and-seek
okay we'll hide and you count come find
us no no no not daddy I'm the nice fish
who wants to be your friend okay okay
ready to go over the one to go my
parents I remember them
wait wait you remember I remember my mom
my dad I have a baby they don't know
where I am
let's go oh no it's just crazy where
exactly are you trying to go to the gym
of the Baltic the junior bacon Bornean
yeah no Dory California's all the way
across the ocean how come every time
we're on the edge of this reef one of us
is trying to leave for once can't we
just enjoy the view how can you be
talking about the new and I remembered
my pan no we've done our ocean travels
that part of our lives is open the only
reason to travel in the first place
don't have to travel did you hear that
was that your what Stan I just I heard
someone say hello yeah there's a lot of
fish here anybody literally anybody
could have just settle up here where am
I looking there
oh hi I'm dory yeah well we're your
parents
hi I've lost my family
where did you see them last I forgot I
was looking for something and I okay
totally get it
date night I suffer from short-term
memory loss it runs in my family at
least I think it does where are they
dory they're yours look out ah look at
this our friend not take it in whatever
this place is it's a fish ah spoon dude
names Hank I have to find my family
that's a hard one kid yeah I guess
you're stuck here I lost my family that
is so sad you're going through not a
great swimmer our friend is in there
Walsh the lone Bailey you've gotta use
your application oh I feel stupid
poor babies let me get that for you she
should just pick two and let's go dad
what I'm kidding
I get the feeling they're shushing us
for a reason like something with one big
eye tentacles and snappy thing well
that's very specific but something like
somewhere out there is my family I can't
find him on my own I don't want to be
touched sorry that's okay
everybody does it nothing to be ashamed
of I just think you trust bet that he's
eating a cop just keep swimming
yeah does this mean we have to say
goodbye to Dori I don't know why I
thought I could do this Dori you are
about to find your parents and when you
do that you'll be huh sea lions they are
natural predators they could pounce at
any moment top my don't you are you oh
don't you worry about a thing oh I know
isn't it great now I've gotta be totally
six California's got a gnarly chomp
Mirza
if you're gonna hurl just do me a solid
head to the back Michelle lean out and
go for distance
looking for my parents at the brooch of
the Atlantic or the jewel may help
exactly how you gonna find your peering
you remember what they look like I'm a
bit new to the memory thing so can't say
for sure but something tells me they
were mostly blue with maybe yellow
that's right
also I'm pretty sure I'm gonna know that
when I see them we're family by the way
crossing the ocean is the kind of thing
you should only do once what time are
okay California's coming up me
today's the day our field trip to the
Stingray migration Erie migration
migration is about going oh oh which is
where your bra how do the stingrays all
know where to go
instinct something deep inside you that
feels so familiar that have to listen to
it oh my mom my dad I have a family we
will never forget you Dorie forgive you
I miss them you know what that feels
like
yes isn't it great now I'm gonna be
totally back
can you help
sorry not a great swimmer I think you
swim beautifully day yes Dory yes you
know her friends no it was so much fun
cuz I tell you a story and then you'd
completely forget about it and I get to
tell it to you over and over again I'm
looking for my family are you crazy
it's too dangerous kittens and mommy Oh
Neptune I'm sorry I got a blink how do
you hold your eyes open that long
hello hey you hi can you help me not
good
hey you Oh spinner
huh thank goodness hi I'm Dorian names
Hank how are you yeah I'm small so what
you be in quarantine oh no how long do I
have ahead - bye hey man don't get
hysterical oh not good what what is it
what happened oh that there is bad news
it's a transport tag for fish you can't
cut it inside the Institute they get
transferred to permanent digs an
aquarium
so what exhibited you're from wait I'm
from an exhibit which one I have to get
there oh that's a hard one kid unless
net never work it's too crazy what do
you mean just tell me I'm okay with
crazy you know I could see that well
there's one thing I can think of to help
you get to your family if I just hey you
take me to find them why didn't I think
of that
no no no if I just take your tag I can
take your place on the transport truck
then you can go back inside and find
your family all you have to do is give
me the tag tag oh there's a lag on my
fin oh how could you forget your tag on
your film oh no I'm sorry I I suffer
from short-term memory loss you don't
remember what we were talking about
mm-hmm
this is it kid roaches here we go and
wait here we go wait are you serious
you understand I totally understand now
okay mm-hmm good what were we talking
about
my family I have to find them they're
blue with maybe yellow is right you
should just pick two and let's go dad
what I'm kidding Wow in 3G June 17 can
you please keep it down over there my
head hurts
who's that that's my neighbor Paisley he
was brought in with a head injury I know
you're talking about me destiny he
thinks he can't use this echolocation
but I've overheard the doctors time
right there's not a thing like every
word you're saying about me what's a
collocation well baby's head is supposed
to put out a call and the echo helps him
find objects far away
oh but apparently he's still healing no
I know you're talking about me
I really can't echo like I have this
conversation again I hit my head very
hard out there see how swollen it is
head is supposed to be big you're a
beluga we know I know where my parents
are there in um what's it called the
place a soap and lotion lotion open
ocean open ocean I know where that is
that's the exhibit located right next to
I don't care easy if you're trying to
get to the open ocean exhibit just go
through the pipes through the pipes
great through the pipes yep takes you
less swim straight look at it oh that's
a lot of direction steps did you get
that Hank they all do all that uh yeah
great let's go I'm not going with you I
won't fit you have to go by yourself um
that's that gun I see I can't because
I'm I'm not so good with directions well
that's too bad a deal's a deal
you want to find your parents that's how
you get to him now give me your name but
hey I can't go in the pipes alone I'll
forget we're not my problem hey have you
seen the year's most unforgettable movie
I can't remember well then see it again
good idea
Suzuki finding dory have you seen her
Rigby gee
I remembered something my mom I remember
her now
I miss her you know what that feels like
I'm Tommy Rogers your parents are gonna
be overjoyed to see you
I have a family I can't believe I'm
gonna see my parents I mean we have so
much to catch up on not that I remember
any of it or anything that we did
together
oh okay where is everyone finding dory
oh wait a second that sounds like a fun
challenge Hey
Dory's missing we've gotta find her
where is everyone
everyone let's work together we can find
her
don't cry mommy don't cry
dori dori dori the middle of the night
dad
Dory sleep swimming she's talking in her
sleep
Deutsch there's a lot of things in her
sleep okay hand me the ratchet wrench so
I can fix it yeah when she starts sleep
swimming again I'm sure this was a
one-time thing
so can we just all go back to Dori Dori
Wow I remembered something that's not
possible is it okay is it like a picture
in your head and then you think I've
seen this before I just use the word
before which means I'm remembering
something what was I talking about so my
family they're out there somewhere I
have to find them
my remembers are they important
something important what
something about a clam or no an oyster
no mollusk something I don't know oh hey
wait up
to just pick two and let's go dad what
I'm kidding
I get the feeling they're shushing us
for a reason like something with one big
eyed tentacles and snappy things well
that's four